- Thank you very much, Judy.
And thank you all of you
beautiful people for being here
today.
I want to begin by just offering
my thanks and my gratitude
to the Radcliffe, really an
extraordinary opportunity,
I think we all feel, to have
our work honored in this way
and to really discover
what these projects are.
And so in that spirit, most of
what I'll be presenting today
really are things
that I've begun
to think about in the
last couple of months
since I've been here.
So I ask your patience and for
you to receive it in that way.
And so I thank you.
I thank you for honoring
my work and for honoring
our work together and
having us here for the year.
Thankful-- also have
the two students
from UC Riverside who've
begun programs here
at Harvard this year.
And [INAUDIBLE] and Gabriella,
I dedicate this to you.
And Rebecca as well--
she's come in the back.
As I am getting ready to
speak at length about ghosts,
inheritance, and generations
and generations of ghosts, which
is to say about certain
others who are not
present nor presently living,
either to us, inside us,
or outside us, it is
in the name of justice,
Derrida, Specters of Marx.
In the beginning there was
ice, glacial ice, now heavy
with the weight of human history
bearing down from one layer
to the next.
It records a solemn
imprint of human loss,
the collapse of
indigenous populations
across this hemisphere
in the 16th century
is legible in the
geological record.
The so-called Orbis Spike
refers to a measurable drop
in carbon dioxide
levels recorded
in the Antarctic glacial ice
core in the precise period
of my study, 1570 to 1620.
To explain the Orbis Spike,
some climate change scientists
conclude that the
mortality crisis suffered
by native peoples led
to a near cessation
of indigenous
agriculture followed
by a period of
rapid reforestation.
After the cataclysm,
the earth strangely
appears to gasp as the
indigenous population tumbles
to its nadir, a sharp intake
of breath, as if in response
to some trauma.
Last year, two
British climatologists
argued that the
16th century Orbis
Spike is the preferred boundary
marker for the beginning
of the Anthropocene.
Their intriguing yet
contested conclusion
is that it is
precisely this moment
of human-wrought
catastrophe that
signals the current
geological age, the age
of the Anthropocene, in
which human activity is
the dominant influence on
climate and the environment.
The human catastrophe that
orients my reflections
this afternoon is thus
legible in geological time.
Ice is more penetrable to the
suffering of humans than God,
it would seem.
In Mexico, both the Spanish
and indigenous survivors
of the collapse regarded
the Christian God
as a remote and dispassionate
observer of the events
He Himself had wrought.
My concern is precisely to
explore religious experience
in this context of
crisis and calamity,
religion at the dawn
of the Anthropocene.
So I'll begin by saying that my
intention is to first provide
some background
conceptually to what
I want to talk about
today, to propose
some conceptual categories.
And then I want
to look at the way
in which the sort of
Christian, the landscape
of the Christian imaginary
is shaped in this period,
both for the Spanish and
for indigenous communities.
And I want to look at the
way, the divergence, really,
of these landscapes of the
imaginary after the collapse,
and in doing that, to show
how the church itself sort
of shapes itself, defines
itself, and reconstitutes
itself as an institution
after this cataclysm.
In the New World,
the Spanish referred
to each ravaging epidemic
as a mortandad, a death
event of apocalyptic scale.
So my story this afternoon
begins with the mortandad,
with the mortality
crisis itself.
And the story I will tell is
one of conquest and crisis
of affliction, of devastation
and disaster, an intimate story
told up close, which is the way
of historians, but with the eye
to the larger
implications for ourselves
and our self-understanding,
which is the way of scholars
of religion.
My argument is this,
that the mortandad,
the indigenous mortality
crisis of the 16th century
is the point of Genesis, the
cosmological point of origin
for Christianity
and the New World.
Born from this moment,
Christianity in the Americas,
I imagine as an Ecclesia ex
Mortuis, a church from the dead
and a church of the dead.
The Ecclesia ex Mortuis is
always defined in relation
to the death event, as to
the dead left in its wake.
The Ecclesia ex Mortuis
orients and reorients itself
in relation to the mortandad
that defines its origin,
not just in relation to the
singular death event of disease
and mortality crisis, but in
relation to the multiple death
worlds wrought by colonialism.
Forged by the death event,
the Ecclesia ex Mortuis
is defined by the dead and
by those who survived them,
by those who claimed
the dead and those who
have abandoned them,
those who had given up
and those who persisted.
As the Ecclesia ex Mortuis,
the New World church
is not a phoenix, rising from
flames, remade and reborn.
Rather, the Ecclesia ex
Mortuis, the religion
that emerges from the disaster
of colonialism and collapse,
is a religion
rescued from rubble,
rescued without
necessarily being
redeemed, a salvaged religion.
So I want to stop
and say something
here about the relationship
between epidemics
and colonialism.
In the 16th century, indigenous
peoples and Spanish observers
struggled to try to understand
the origins, the cause,
of indigenous death,
of their own deaths.
And there was no
consensus, I would say.
Was it bad conditions,
hard labor, the violence
of the conquest?
Was it particular
vulnerability to disease?
Those questions were
unresolved in the time.
And I think they're still
unresolved among historians
today, those who are considering
these contexts today.
I see, really, that
epidemics are not
just the kind of antecedent that
paves the way for colonialism,
nor are they sequelae
of colonialism.
But really, they are
co-identifying with it.
They are inseparable from it.
So they are-- and that
is why I regard them
as man-made in essence, so the
origins of man-made mass death.
And for those of you who know
the work of Edith Wyschogrod
She is here.
And you will see her again.
And I want to say that
in my thinking about how
to engage the dead,
I've been really aided
by the work of Vince
Brown, who's here today,
and thinking about the dead as
a generative social force that
shapes social institutions
and shapes history.
So I'm grateful for
that insight that I
bring to these materials.
So I'm going to now talk
a little bit about what
this collapse is and
talk about what illness
particularly we're
talking about here.
And then I'm going to
move on to really look
at these two landscapes.
And I'm going to look at two
very particular documents, two
very particular
kinds of materials,
to try to get at the ways that
the Christian imagination is
shaped in this
moment of collapse.
And in general-- so I'm working
with unpublished manuscript
materials from the Achivo
de Indies, the Archive
of the Indies in Seville.
But today, while I'll
refer to some of those,
I'm actually going to focus
on published sources that
may be a little more
familiar to some people.
So the topic, the sort of period
of collapse in Mexico of steep
decline over a course
of about 50 years,
and the first an
epidemic of smallpox.
And these numbers,
these are a variation
of Cook and Borah, the famous
Berkeley demographers' numbers.
At the middle of
the 20th century,
they radically revised the count
of the indigenous population
of Mexico and of the
Americas, really.
And they radically
revised it up.
And this number of 22
million to start really
is sort of on the middle
low end of their estimate.
This author has chosen to
anchor the numbers there.
And then I do want to say that
I disagree with the suggestion
of [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH] as
the name, the Nahua people,
the Nahua name for the disease.
And I think it I think the
consensus is probably typhus,
in 1545.
But you can see these
steep periods of decline.
And probably, the
steepest one, really,
is that 1545, where you
really see that plummet.
This is the period
that I'm interested in.
And I think of it as
the corner of collapse,
basically, that point
at which the population
tumbles to its very lowest
point and remains there
for about 250 years,
never really to recover.
So I'm looking at that
precise bend, that corner.
And the illness that
the indigenous people
called Cocolitzli.
I'll talk about that a little
bit more in a minute, has been,
I think, fairly
conclusively determined
to be an epidemic of
hemorrhagic fever,
an arenaviral hemorrhagic
fever, characterized
by internal and
external hemorrhage,
transmitted by
rodents to humans.
And a really interesting
study in 2000
attributed it to kind of
tectonic agricultural shifts
under colonial rule, in
particular the introduction
of wheat and the increase
in stores of wheat
and also stores of corn that
increased the rodent reservoir
population.
So I want to say, they're
not. virgin soil diseases.
These are native-born.
This is a native-born illness.
And it's an illness that
overwhelmingly takes the lives
of indigenous peoples.
But there are also some
Spanish who are susceptible,
as well as Africans in Mexico.
But the predominantly
affected by far
is the indigenous population.
So there's a map.
People like maps.
So I'm really thinking about New
Spain overall, a larger story,
I want to tell about American
Christianity, sort of you
can think about when we talk
about the origins of American
Christianity, we think of
Plymouth Rock, Plymouth
Plantation.
And I want to shift that access.
I'm always trying to
shift Tenochtitlan now
becomes the center of the
origins of the American, story
of American Christianity.
But largely, what I'm
talking about here,
and the sources come from
the larger area of the Vice
Royalty of Mexico,
and this is where
there's a real, one of the
large demographic centers,
population centers, before
the arrival of Europeans here,
the Amazon, the
Andes, and really also
that I'm looking at the
Nahua area and the Maya area.
And those are the sources
that I'm working with.
So for those who want a
reminder about this period, what
I'm really talking about
is the early decades
of Spanish mission
in the Americas.
The first friars are
Franciscan mendicant friars.
They arrive in 1524.
There are 12 of them,
a symbolic number.
They march into Mexico City.
They process into Mexico City,
where they are ceremonially
received by Cortez,
who reverences them.
I think he kisses their
skirts or their hands
and really turns over.
So the spiritual
conquest then follows
on the heels of the military
conquest in a very real way.
So my concern really
here are mostly
the mendicant orders--
the Franciscans,
the Augustinian, the
Dominicans, and those
who are working in communities,
indigenous Indian communities,
Indian pueblos, and their
sort of millennial dream
for a new Christendom, an
American Christendom that
would guide them over the
next 50 years between 1524,
I would say, in the onset
of this epidemic, that sort
of fantasy, that desire.
And over those
first five decades,
I think we can read in the
record fluctuations of optimism
and despair for the friars.
In the big picture,
I want to say
what happens in the course of
the epidemic, so this final,
that corner of collapse,
when that corner is turned,
is that the mendicant orders
really come to perceive--
and you'll see the
evidence in the sources
that I talk about
here-- but they
come to perceive that the
New World church is over.
It's come to an end.
With the death of the
indigenous population,
there is no more a
future, or a future
as they imagined this sort of
indigenous Indian, Christian,
Franciscan, version of
Christianity, of Christendom.
And so what happens
is they retreat
from the missionary frontier.
They retreat from
pueblos de indios,
the indigenous communities.
They consolidate their
personnel in urban areas,
in Mexico City and
other urban areas.
And they really thrive
and prosper there.
And then their
future and their fate
really comes to shape
kind of the New World city
urbanization.
And from this, I think, we
see the origins of Mestizo
Christianity and the
origins of the Baroque
also, so that retreat into
the urban areas, consolidation
in the urban areas, the rise
of Baroque Christianity.
I want to talk about sort
of effective positionalities
that I'm I've been struggling
with in my sources,
trying to get my
head around in terms
of the ways in which the
friars see themselves
and understand their labor.
So in my work, I'm coming
very close to them.
I'm intimately involved in
their writings and their lives.
And I'm thinking the sort of
self-perception, their identity
as conservadores de indios
is really at the core.
So they are conservers of
the indigenous population.
That becomes, very early,
part of their identity.
They are trying to keep
indigenous people alive.
And then what happens is there's
a pairing in the manuscript
sources that I'm
coming across, which
is a pairing of a kind of dual
mission for the mendicants,
which is the mission of
conservacion and convercion.
So conversion and conservation
become a joined mission.
And I think there is this
sort of affect, then,
that comes from this moment of
worry, anxiety, care, concern,
pity, poignancy, and
this sort of Pieta vision
which I've published before
and think about this image
quite a bit, this Jose Clemente
Orozco's Friar and the Indian,
Franciscan and the Indian,
a sort of an image of care
and rescue, even as the person
is dying in the frier's arms.
Ultimately, I think in the
epidemic that I'm looking at,
the friars come to
realize that that identity
as conservadores de idios,
that they have failed,
that they have failed to
conserve the population.
So for example, in 1582,
the Augustinian provincial--
so right in the end of the
epidemic-- Pedro Suarez de
Escobar writes the
Spanish king, and he
is morning this
collapse, this endpoint
of the indigenous population.
And he writes, it was
a disastrous shipwreck,
in which our holy religion has
sunk to the bottom of the sea,
so the sense of it
as over, as final.
You know, and the reality is,
of course, in that retreat
to the urban areas, they
prosper, the religious orders
prosper.
So in a sense,
though, the church
has ended before it's even
really begun, in a sense.
So I want to talk about
landscape now, so the remaining
time, I want to explore
these two landscapes
of the Christian imagination,
the Christian imaginaire that
emerged after this epidemic or
in the wake of the epidemic.
And the first for the friars,
for the religious personnel,
for the Spanish missionaries,
is the collapse, the death,
is most tangible,
most immediate,
in their perception
of a depopulated land,
a land of empty roads,
roads that have been emptied
of people, that are abandoned.
And so this is the landscape
that I want to think about,
this idea of empty roads.
And in some way, I think the
landscape of the Ecclesia ex
Mortuis is really a landscape
of the dead, a land of the dead.
And so this is a source here
that, a Spanish source, that's
writing about the Miccatlalli,
which is the Nahua
concept of a land of the
dead, a tierra de difuntos,
and that this is
how they regard,
this is in this moment how the
Spanish Christian imaginary
in Mexico is regarding the New
World, the landscape of the New
World.
So empty roads,
abandoned roads, this
is a tangible sign as evidence
of death of the Indians.
And there's a way in which
these roads, I think,
are full of pathos and
sentiment and drive them forward
into the cities and in
retreat from that vision.
So some of the
documents I'm working
with, the bishop of Mexico,
grand inquisitor, Pedro
Contreras, kind of was holed up
in the course of the epidemic
in his home, his cathedral home.
And then right as it's
crested, after about 18 months.
He comes out.
And he walks 800 leagues
to survey his diocese.
He had postponed this
trip from most two years.
And then he writes a letter
describing a wasteland.
It was much to consider
and contemplate,
he writes, to see the
land so depopulated,
a land that in the
time of Montezuma
was swarming with people.
It seemed like there was no
remedy that it could ever
be that way again, because the
Indians that remain in the land
are being consumed
with great speed.
He goes on, having witnessed
the state of the provinces,
their greatly reduced
populations, and the sites
from antiquity that
so clearly show
how great the
population once was,
it fills one with grief and pity
to see these superb ruins which
so clearly marked the great
diminishment of the population.
Along the same lines, the bishop
of Michoacan, at the same time,
writes-- he's an
Augustinian friar.
He'd been in Mexico
for half a century.
And in October of
'81, 1581, he writes,
one feels the loss most in
the loneliness and emptiness
of the roads and towns.
And what is most terrifying
is that it does not
cease to continue to take lives
here and there, even though
so very few remain.
Mexico City was truly a
valley of tears, una valle
de lagrimas.
So I want now to
bring this reading
into a more familiar document.
This is Sahagun, Bernardino,
Franciscan recorder,
chronicler, editor
of encyclopedias,
I would say, in
the 16th century.
His history of the
things of New Spain
is 12-volume,
encyclopedic-- 12 books,
really, bound in
three volumes that
chronicle the culture
of Mesoamerica, probably
our most important
source for understanding
Mesoamerican populations
before the conquest,
because the Spanish destroyed
much artifacts and objects that
might have assisted us.
So the interesting
thing about this book
is that the Getty Villa, a
couple, maybe a decade back
or something-- in
the last 10 years--
repatriated a bunch of
Italian masterpieces,
sent them back to Italy.
The Getty Villa is
this sort of a hotbed
of Greek and Roman antiquities.
And so they had
repatriated, they
had returned these Italian
works with the understanding,
the agreement, that they
would be able to receive
on loan Italian masterpieces.
So the moment arises,
and they say--
the Getty Villa
curatorial staff say--
what we want, the first thing we
want, is the Florentine Codex.
So Sahagun's codex,
his three volumes,
are in the library in Florence.
And they were shocked right,
because they're expecting
some Italian masterwork.
And the person, apparently,
on the other end of the phone
didn't even know what this
was and had to figure it out.
So for the first time
in 400 years in 2010,
one volume of the Florentine
Codex came to the Getty Villa.
And it was on display there.
And I took students to see it.
And at the opening, I believe
it was the ambassador, one
of the ambassador,
Mexican ambassador, said,
we may not be able
to let this go back.
We might have to keep it here.
So really, really,
everyone sort of
laughed nervously in that
moment, like, you know,
is he serious?
But really quite extraordinary--
so the work is beautifully
illustrated.
So Sahagun is collaborating.
So in the midst of the epidemic,
of this particular epidemic--
and Dinah [INAUDIBLE]
has described
this beautifully, the art
historian-- in the midst
of this epidemic, Sahagun is
holed up in a studio workshop
with perhaps some 22,
some portion of 22
indigenous artists,
and illustrators,
and experts, cultural experts,
creating this document.
And it is Nahua on the one
side with Spanish translation
on the other.
So the original text is
Nahua, and the Spanish
is the translation, and
then these gorgeous images,
and just an extraordinary,
beautiful work.
So what I have been
working on, I think,
is something that,
so far I don't
know if anyone is
writing about this,
but I've found the sort
of interesting thing
in Sahagun's, in book 11
of his volume dedicated
to the kind of earthly
things, to objects, to things
of the natural world,
in chapter eight.
So it's a catalog of indigenous
culture, basically, and flora
and fauna of the New World.
And so what he's
done is this section
is supposed to be dedicated
to caminos, to roads,
in the Nahua culture before
the arrival of the Spanish.
And the whole
12-series volume ends
with the arrival of Cortez.
That's the final scene
of these 12 books.
But anyway, so on this
side, it's all about roads.
And the indigenous scribes, the
Nahua scribes, have written.
I'm going to read some of the
things they say about roads.
But then on the left side,
rather than translation,
we have a really
interesting interruption,
which is Sahagun
takes this moment
to write about the epidemic.
And there six pages
dedicated to the epidemic.
And he sort of fit it in.
So this sort of landscape that
he is painting in the narrative
is really one of an imperfect,
broken, Christian orb,
in which Christianity has
traveled across the globe,
kind of failed
wherever it's gone,
and has finally come to Mexico,
where it's also just failed.
It's ended.
The Christian mission has ended.
And I'm going to read from that.
But first, I want to read from
this these incredible Nahua
discussion of roads that
he doesn't translate.
And in the main published
version of this,
the author, the editors,
decided to translate the Nahua
and to kind of leave
out the Spanish.
So the sort of litany of roads
that the Nahua scribes offer--
so for example, regarding
main or principal roads,
they write, I travel the road.
I travel the main road.
I widen it, broaden it,
narrow it, make it narrow.
I sweep the road.
I clean it up.
I improve it.
I take it straight ahead.
I go directly along it.
I go straight on it.
I go down it.
I go up it.
I travel directly along it.
I follow its curve.
I follow its curves.
I double back on it.
I follow the winding road.
I break off my journey along it.
I regard the smooth road.
I remove trees from the road.
I clean the road.
I improve the road.
I place myself on the main road.
I fill the main road with sheep.
I herd them.
I bring them to the main road.
I join the main road.
I come to join it.
I join it there.
I depart from it, so this
sort of litany of roads.
And then meanwhile,
Sahagun writes,
having passed through
mountains and valleys and roads
of diverse kinds, it seems
to me the opportune time
to talk about the roads that
the church itself has traveled,
until arriving at
this last dwelling,
where it is now
a pilgrim, sowing
the doctrine of the gospel.
And he goes on to say as the
church has passed from Europe,
from Palestine into Europe into
Germany, Italy into Africa,
it's failed pretty much
everywhere it's gone.
Right It's failed in
each of these places
to take deep roots.
Mexico, for Sahagun, was the
land of infinite possibility.
But he writes,
the Catholic faith
has found infertile
territory here.
There were once a diversity of
people in this land, he writes.
But these are pretty
much finished.
And those that remain are on
the road to their end as well.
It is a great land here to sow
Christianity, but difficult
to harvest.
It seems to me that the
Catholic faith is not
long for these lands,
because the people head
to their end with great haste,
not only for the bad treatment
they receive, but
because of the diseases
God has sent upon them.
But it seems to me
that our Lord has
opened a new road for
the church, the road
to Asia and the Philippines.
And as the Catholic
Church is planted there,
I think will last
for many years,
because for this
land of New Spain,
the Catholic faith has
done nothing more than pass
through it as through a road.
So that sort of landscape is
really quite extraordinary.
So here's this final bit,
just one last thing here.
I think what's
really striking to me
about Sahagun's
interruption of his work
to write about the
epidemic and to reflect
on this particular
corner of collapse
is the way in which it's a
rupture, in so many ways,
from the rest of the work.
And then also, I want to
say a temporal rupture,
because the work
otherwise closes
with the arrival of Cortez.
But here's this other
really, another rupture.
So there's a little asterisks.
I don't know if you
can see that there.
And then it refers to a
section right down there.
It refers you to that section.
So he's asking the reader,
future imagined reader--
I don't know who--
to pray for us.
So he says, [SPEAKING SPANISH],
so pray for us that this ends.
Because if it lasts any
longer, everything is over.
So for Sahagun and his brethren,
the Christian landscape now
a marred landscape, the
landscape of the Ecclesia ex
Mortuis, a broken landscape,
an empty landscape.
So I want to shift gears now
and bring the-- this will be
the last five, 10 minutes here.
I want to talk now
about how I'm trying
to access-- It's
more difficult--
but how I'm trying to
access indigenous responses
to the epidemic.
I don't have
indigenous languages.
But also, the sources even in
this period for this material
are hard to find and
few exist at all.
So I'm need to look at published
materials, visual sources,
as well.
But I want to kind of contrast
the, what I would say,
the emerging Christian imaginary
of indigenous communities
at the same time, in the
same corner of collapse,
in the same crisis, and
how indigenous communities,
Christian communities, are
reconstituting themselves
in the wake of this epidemic.
And so I want to say something
about indigenous Christianity.
So I would say one of the
questions that really drives
part of my work is to
think about this paradox
of colonial imposition
of Christianity
and the fact of indigenous
Christian faith.
That's the kind of
thing I struggle with,
how to talk about that,
how to write about that.
And so I want to say that
there's an argument-- I'm not
very versed with this
material-- but there's
an argument that
says that epidemics,
disease, and the
origins of Christianity
in the first century, first
centuries, that those really
helped solidify the
Christian church.
Christianity was
particularly prepared
to deal with broken
body in this way,
with illness, with disease.
And also, there was sort
of a social factor that
allowed for Christians
to care for each other
and then facilitated
their survival.
I don't see evidence
for anything
like that in this period.
What I want to say is
that in central Mexico,
according to my, what I
have come to understand
my sources, that in most
indigenous communities,
were not-- I would say, and
I've written-- they immediately
kind of recognize the potency
of the Christian sacred.
So there was a fairly
immediate willingness
to accept where conflict
and violence occurred
was rather around two
areas of contest--
one, Christian exclusivism,
Christianity and no other.
And then the other is
Spanish-European control
over local Christian practice.
So communities of
indigenous Christians
fought those two struggles.
And that's where, often,
the greatest violence
happened as a result, as
indigenous communities insisted
on that.
So I want to say that
this epidemic does not
make people more Christian.
It does not make
more Christians.
It is the communities
that already understood
themselves to be
Christian reasserted
that in a particular frame.
And so I want to talk
about that as I close.
So this is a particular document
that kind of gets at or sheds
some light, I think, on
how indigenous communities
were seeing this epidemic.
So Cocolitzli, the name
that they give it, coco
from the Nahuatl, demolish,
dismember, destroy, itzli,
or litzli, blood, demolished
by blood, destroyed by blood,
laid waste by blood.
And you can see here
is an illustration.
This is a codex from 1607
by an anonymous indigenous
author, written in Nahuatl for
an elite indigenous audience.
And it's an annal, so
every year has its events.
And this is for the year 1576.
And you can see he's
kind of bleeding here
on this cross, which I think
is kind of interesting,
and with the friar with
sunglasses or something.
I don't know what's
going on with him.
But anyway, so what the Nahua
says accompanying these images
about this epidemic is it
talks about how the friars went
home and home, trying to
care for the sick for a time,
trying to rescue the sick.
But then that ended.
And the author writes--
this is the Spanish.
I don't need to
read the Spanish.
Basically, that is when
the bells stopped ringing.
They stopped ringing for
the dead, for the burials.
And it was as if we had been
abandoned in the church.
But the sense that as the
mendicant orders are retreating
from indigenous
communities, they've
abandoned both the
living and the dead.
So the sources that I've
found myself rereading
over the last
couple months, these
are very famous maps, the Mapas
of the Relaciones Geograficas.
They're a set.
I think there's 167
of them in existence.
They were part of an answer
to a survey circulated
by King Philip II in 1576,
thereabout, something
like that.
And it coincides--
rather incidentally,
this survey coincided with
this period of collapse.
There are 50 questions.
These are circulated to pueblos,
communities, all over Mexico,
all over, actually, New Spain.
I'm focusing on
the ones in mostly
in the central--
in Mexico proper.
But question 10 in the
survey asks for a map.
And the idea was that the king
wanted to survey his colony.
He wanted to understand what
resources there might be,
was trying to create
together, thinking
these would create a
comprehensive map that he
could use in some way.
And both the answers
to the questions
are often referred to indigenous
leaders in the communities,
because they're asking
about local history,
and local resources,
and local languages
and then the
commissioning of the maps
also, in many instances, they're
done by indigenous artists
and artisans.
And they turn out
to be completely
useless for colonial purposes,
completely illegible,
completely bizarre, right?
But they've been read.
But they coincide
precisely to this period
of the end of this epidemic.
And so I've been
trying to reread them,
because I'm in visual
sources and visual materials.
I've been trying to read
them as documents that
are responding to the epidemic.
And so the way that
they've been regarded
in the past by scholars--
for example, Serge Gruzinski,
beautiful scholar who
writes about this period
and writes about these
maps as memories to order.
They are nostalgic.
They are backward-looking.
They are recalling
a time of order.
And we have now entered
a time of disorder.
And I am proposing to read them
in a different way as actually
a projection of
local communities
into the future in a kind
of Christian landscape,
written on a
Christian landscape.
And where scholars who have
looked at them before are
interested in indigenous
motifs, indigenous writing,
pictographs,
iconography, I'm really
interested to trace
the Christian images
and Christian symbols
on these maps.
And so you can see the
intersection of roads
and churches is something
I've been thinking quite a bit
about.
So there's one map in particular
that I want to talk about.
This is one of the
more famous maps.
And so my suggestion,
basically, the way
that I'm reading
these, because they're
sent to the king, that
these local communities,
these local communities
of indigenous Christians
have now mapped
Christian architecture,
Christian buildings,
the Christian church,
Christian symbols, onto their
local cosmological imagination.
And so they are, I'm suggesting,
a kind of proffered covenant--
covenants often
follow cataclysm--
for a way forward for
these local communities.
And if I had more time, I would
talk about the altepetl, which
is the Nahua ethnic unit that
is the sort of thing on which
indigenous communities
insist in the conquest
that that will survive.
It is the ethnic state,
could be very small.
There were 300 of them in
the larger part of Mexico
when the Spanish arrived.
And so my argument is
that these maps and like
this map of
Teozacoalco that they
are inscribing that Christian
imaginary onto the landscape
of the altepetl and proposing
a local sovereign Christianity,
bounded, territorially bounded.
These are boundary
markers all around,
these pictographs of covenants
and boundary markers,
marking space and sort of
inscribing Christian space
within this frame.
And I want to say,
of course, if you
want to read Mesoamerican
maps, David Carrasco
is the person to help with this.
He's written
beautifully about that.
So what captures
my attention here
is at the very
center of this map
is this image of a
church, and next to it,
an early colonial
palace, and the way
that that interfaces with
these other figures, which
are indigenous lineages,
royal lineages, and this space
of this town, this
altepetl, that
interacts with only outward
to its indigenous history.
I think about-- it's
hard to see here,
and the quality of the
slide isn't that good--
but these roads, thinking
about roads and landscape,
have footprints, which is very
traditional to pre-Hispanic
Mesoamerican cartography.
They have footprints on them
that run all around the church,
so thinking about
circumambulation
and the way in which the person
is bound to that community,
and the sacred is made through
walking, and the paths that are
walked around this church.
So this-- I think that
many of these maps
can be read as a
proffered covenant.
We move forward as
Christian on these terms.
And so here, you
have, for example,
this royal lineage
that kind of grows out
of the church palace structure
in reference to that structure.
So I'll just close by
saying that in kind
of tracing these two
Christian landscapes,
distinct Christian
landscapes, one that projects
into the future, indigenous
Christianity into the future,
and one that suggests
that Christianity
is dead in any
form we would have
wanted, kind of delineating
those two trajectories.
In thinking about the
collapse and the cataclysm,
I have to say, and the way in
which this cataclysmic event
plays on both geological,
religious, cosmological,
and cartographic registers--
it plays out on those
registers-- that in
thinking about it,
I thought a lot about
how I position myself
as a scholar in relation to
this cataclysm and in relation
to the dead.
And I am moved by Edith
Wyschogrod and her thinking
about, her call to the
heterological historian.
She writes, in writing
about the human death event,
before saying thus it was,
the heterological historian is
willing to pronounce the words,
it ought not to have been thus.
So, thank you.
[APPLAUSE]